josh jackson just dropped his new
canadian audible original oracle 2 the
dreamland murders now this is the
follow-up to his audiobook oracle and it
gives us a chance to check in on all
things josh
i'm not going to be
ignored so many people are excited for
the new fatal attraction series have you
guys started shooting we start in the
beginning right after canada then what
can you tease us about it what our story
does is it allows you to get into the
psychology of the glenn close character
to really understand
the who and the why and the where
actually just like a week ago spoke with
glenn close and she's totally on board
for this series i'm just hoping
that they will go into
why she behaved the way she did so she
was at the met ball i worked with glenn
close many many many years ago and so i
had the opportunity to be like hey i'm
doing this thing and i hope you think
it's cool because i think it's cool and
she was totally on board with him
with et canada we're always covering you
know the latest red carpet and
you and your lady jody turner smith are
just couple goals everyone's obsessed
with you i would like to be humble
because i am canadian and it is better
for us to be that way but i cannot be
humble we smashed it at the med gala
you were saying you're at home with your
daughter where you're reading where the
wild things are yeah which is very
exciting how nice is it being able to
share those moments with her i mean nice
is not the world so i read where the
wild things are too early she wasn't
interested and then i read it to her
again like
two three weeks ago and she was engaged
this time it's just the most amazing
being a father is awesome